ah messing around with that already
forgive me
control this
that's a little better
yeah should i just kill that i don't
know
i don't know
can people see me am i actually
is this actually live somebody tell me
because i don't know
what i'm doing oh good people can't see
me
i learned earlier this week um i learned
the role of mr collins in an upcoming
production of pride and prejudice very
cool this is just blowing me out i gotta
turn this light off
all right give up
ah
congratulations castile um
still gonna be blown out because this is
just
how maybe if i take i'm gonna keep
fiddling with this because this this has
been bothering me
more than it used to
so what if i kill that one
you get my uh my very very fancy
super basic pants that i'm wearing just
be thankful that i'm wearing pants
because this could have gone this could
have gone very different
ah just got my degree
it was good so i'm celebrating by
breaking out
all of the water uh yay for water
my prepared beverage ah it's too hot
so i won't be uh partaking of that for a
little bit
i am uh i'm a little frustrated i would
i like i've bought a webcam so that i
won't have to keep streaming from my
phone
what i didn't realize because i'm at
this point i'm in the habit
of setting up the live stream from my
phone
and what i didn't realize was if you set
it up
even if it's scheduled to start later
from your phone you can't
pick that up from the computer
you have to set it up on the computer so
if i wanted to make use of my new webcam
i would have had to scrap the room that
i knew about 40
or some odd people were waiting in and i
just said to heck with it i'm gonna try
and have that sorted out um
by uh the next time because well for a
number of reasons the next time
i haven't had a theme for a little bit
uh now
but um there will be there will be for
the next one
because uh the next one i'm still
working out all the details of
what it's gonna look like but it's gonna
kind of be a sort of telethon
uh because i got a tax bill
that i can cover
uh but at the same time it's like um
it's making things really really really
tight
um you said you enjoy among us maybe
play with fans as a patreon perk maybe
possibly uh that's the kind of thing
that like if and when i actually get
caught up
on stuff i i would like to to look into
setting up doing
uh because that's actually the um the
one time that i've played
actually like with other people properly
on the computer as opposed on my phone
and not just a random public
was um was on somebody else's discord
server
that some of the people there set up a
game and i i i really dug the heck out
of it i don't know if i'm
organized enough but again these these
are good things to do but i i
i'm really feeling i'm feeling the
pressure of the book
and i'm feeling how badly backed up um
you know my commissions are
loving the top of the pronoun badge
thank you very much thank you carowind
for that
let's all play a game called
how long can wild last before she cracks
um i think i've already i think i've
already lost that
acting sauce oh i'm i'm suss af
um is among us worth playing
even if you're not playing with people
you know yeah i've been playing for a
couple of months just
doing random public games just realize
that's a bit of a dice roll
in terms of uh depending on how
the person has set it up um because
you can set uh different games of
different ways in terms of things like
movement speed how many imposters there
are what the tasks are like so
um if people fiddle with it too much it
can really
unbalance the game in one direction or
another and sometimes some people are
just dicks
your ability to grief is pretty limited
in terms of what you can do but like
people can still make it unfun or they
just like drop out for the heck of it
did you watch the ball drop yes and it
was one of the most pathetic
things i've ever seen broadcast
it was depressing
i don't know if anybody else watched it
they tried to fill out the crowd with
like the wacky waving inflatable arm
flailing tube men
and it was really sad
my mother's boyfriend has a positive for
cover 19 so that means i'm stuck in
quarantine for a week at best i'm very
sorry to hear that conor
um i hope he recovers all right and i
hope nobody else
uh and your family catches it in general
do you think blue rays are worth the
extra money
or do you just go for dvds i do get
blu-rays
um because at this point like i have a
high enough deaf tv that i can tell the
difference
now i'm it's not i'm not so busy that
i'm gonna re-buy dvd
things that i have on dvd again on
blu-ray
unless something goes wrong with the dvd
like i have my uh my princess mono okay
dvd
uh would skip so that one i replaced
with the blu-ray but if i'm getting
something new for the first time
if i can get it on blu-ray i will and i
i'm missing questions i don't have the
energy to to go back and scroll and
catch up
so usual rules apply the only thing
um the only thing that i that will
guarantee that i can't that i grab your
question
is a super chat and um
anything else i will respond to it as it
comes up but if i miss it you can ask it
again just don't spam the chat
my mods will put an end to that happy to
report i've recovered from the dreaded
disease i'm still reporting for duty oh
thank you joel very happy to hear that
uh
joel is uh is my thumbnail artist
for folks who didn't know if you've
never watched glee then how do you
know about the asian f episode
by the way he got a uh he didn't get a b
got an a minus oh like that
fixes what's wrong with that
you don't have to have seen the show to
know that there's an episode titled
and the asian f like that
i've read about that i looked it up and
confirmed that it wasn't made up because
that was my assumption when i heard
about that i'm like
no they didn't actually then i looked it
up and like oh for
god's sake so what do you mean how did i
know
that's like saying how how do you know
the doctor's a time lord if you've never
watched doctor who somebody told them at
some point
you know the care home i work at has had
a bad outbreak of covet a third of the
residents and half of the staff in my
department have all tested positive
i'm negative for now thank heavens oh
goodness i'm trying to
stay safe as best you can charleston i'm
really sorry to hear that
finally re-watching doctor who and
watching your overdues with it
well i hope that makes it more
entertaining for you um
with a with a nice refreshed view you
can watch my reviews and tell me how
wrong
i am people do enjoy that
would you rather be tied to a chair
gagged and forced to watch the final
season of dexter
or game of thrones
see you you started with tied to a chair
and gagged and and i was hoping for a
more fun
question than that you let me down
that's that's disappointing
i am stalling in my answer yes
[Music]
um
i don't know
i don't know the finale of dexter is
worse
but the the badness of game of thrones
is more it's the entire season's a slow
train wreck
the final season of dexter is just dull
until that last episode so i don't
actually know which is worse
did you enjoy the discourse from the
hell bent video comment section
one guy wrote a flip in essay yes i'm
aware
which honestly kind of speaks to
something that i didn't bring up in the
video because i didn't know how to
i didn't know how to address it in a way
that was going to flow with everything
else
and also that wouldn't sound like i was
calling people out and being a dick and
i'm hoping it doesn't sound like i'm
doing that now
but here's the thing
virtually every defense
of hell bent i've ever read
or heard it
still falls down for me on one of two
reasons
either it involves very elaborate
head canon stuff that is not confirmed
in the episode itself in the text of the
episode where they have to extrapolate
things from about three different places
and take like one line from the episode
itself
in order to make this theory make sense
so eat and again
if that's your head canon that's fine
but you need to acknowledge
that's what you're working with that's
your head cannon
but then even if they're right even if
what they lay out with these elaborate
long things is in fact
the intention of the
of the episode there's still a problem
because enough people got it wrong
either because they're like me and they
don't understand what the heck's going
on at all
or since i've seen multiple
contradictory theories about what
hellbent means
a bunch of other people came up with a
different read
so something still went wrong
it either makes no sense unless you have
this leopard fan theory
and or there is an intent that actually
matches some of these elaborate theories
but
was poorly communicated to viewers which
is still a failing
this is something i always always always
come back to
if you have to explain it and it doesn't
make sense
to someone viewing it for the first time
then you
failed you have failed in communicating
your intent
now sometimes people just won't get it
that does happen
but if a significant portion of your
audience either
doesn't know what the heck you're doing
or thinks you're doing something
completely different
you screwed up
hey really drives me nuts oh i got super
chats to catch up on okay so let me back
up and do that i think i also saw meg's
name pop up hi meg
um
may oh and also hi carowind hi my mods
and hi every
hi everybody i wish i could catch more
names but like
i i know you i know most you pretty well
same group so
thank you very much from mr will guitar
are you watching the stand also the
wonder woman issue
uh just a modern audience being more
aware in your opinion i never questioned
the body takeover quantum
leap as a kid despite the similarity
so a couple of things there am i
watching the stand no i don't even
remember what it's streaming on
um so the wonder woman issue
the awareness of it is more of a modern
day perspective of it
it does just because it wasn't um as
widely
acknowledged before doesn't mean it
didn't always exist i actually do plan
on tackling a video
on that hopefully later this month if i
can get my act together
so stick a pin in that i'll come back to
it
have you seen fear and loathing in las
vegas we can't stop here
this is bat country yes i've seen it
would you say doctor who fans are kinder
on bad episodes than other fandoms
um
no i don't think there's as much
consensus among modern era doctor who
fans
as to what constitutes a bad episode
but when doctor who fans don't like an
episode
they really don't like this goes for me
too
and that's regardless of their reason
whether their reason is it
didn't work for them it didn't land um
you know and and things like that or
like it
pushes an agenda that they didn't like
they go in hard i i think there's less
consensus uh as to what constitutes
the bad certainly then there was in like
say for
classic fans who usually are pretty on
point
that said i had a um
i had a conversation with i say a friend
he's more of a
friendly nemesis prior to a podcast
record where he said he genuinely likes
warriors warriors of the deep so
who even knows anymore and that was from
high voltage thank you very much
real life jolie hello there
hey you just wanted to ask how bad your
tax bill is and to apologize for
um driving that up by actually giving
you a hundred dollars last year
so uh two things first of all don't
apologize for
um commissioning me for stuff i need to
apologize for you for how long it took
me to
get to that the tax but i don't wanna
i don't wanna actually i'm not
comfortable at this point
saying the number it's several thousand
dollars that i'm dealing with right now
and the thing is this this isn't about
last year's taxes
this was about an error on my taxes from
three years ago and it was an
it was a fluke i'm pretty sure it was a
fluke anyways
on the state taxes like everything was
fine on the federal but the state taxes
something screwed up and something
didn't go through
in terms of what was registered and that
got caught later
in an audit i'm pretty sure they audited
me because i registered a business and
i'm self-employed
but they now caught it and so money owed
interest penalties so uh it's not
actually i
i haven't even tackled the tax bill from
last year yet this is
separate from that so i'll have that to
deal with
in the coming months i've got a oh
i gotta call up my old employers make
sure they're gonna mail my w-2
uh you mentioned earlier you had not
which glee would you ever watch glee or
do a reaction yeah sure if somebody paid
me
hold on i'm gonna i am getting
self-conscious
about about that
so i'm gonna go for a uh more flattering
angle for
my under chin
uh do you think the timelords will ever
come back oh eventually
everything comes back some showrunner
eventually
uh will bring it back
uh do you still go by uh nathaniel are
you exclusively
vera um i i still answer to both
that that hasn't changed
let's see recently got netflix for the
first time i'm feeling a bit spoiled for
choice
what were your top things to watch on
there be shira
uh shira and uh the good place
uh what hypothetical pairing of
companion and doctor
would be the worst
huh
i don't know off the top of my head
um melon the first doctor feels like
that would go
really bad
i was right in the middle of a reptile
zoo and somebody was giving
boost to the goddamn oh yes
joel now quoting um
fear and loathing in las vegas
i was right in the middle of a [ __ ]
reptile zoo someone was giving booze to
these goddamn things
won't be long now before they tear us to
shreds
uh nice glasses thank you
i think i found the perfect song for you
to sing during a live stream without
being demonetized
boreo's sequenza
is that a reference am i supposed to
know that
for the love of god please don't watch
felix the cat the movie it will make
your mind malfunction i wasn't planning
to
again unless somebody pays me
uh thank you for creating your essays is
some of the best i've seen on these
channels oh my gosh
wow um that i i really appreciate that
because like i
the stuff i sink a lot of time into i'm
i'm proud of but
doesn't get a ton of attention
melon anyone would be awful well yes mel
was my default i just had to think about
who would be the worst option
a flaw in hell bent no one brings up is
me
going with clara is dumb she should know
that immortals shouldn't
travel with immortals that they need the
mayflies well i mean
at that point we're dealing with a
version of her that's already lived to
the end of the time so who the heck
knows what conclusions she's come to
i'm not necessarily going to disagree
with you
but yeah like that seems like
so low on the totem pole
of problems with that episode i'm
keeping i'm going to keep adjusting the
camera
if you're not used to that by now i
don't know what to tell you the comment
about you having to redo hellbent review
because take two wasn't in the title
that was a joke well whether it was or
wasn't i wasn't gonna do it
thoughts on the 14th doctor i know you
don't care about gender race etc but
who's
uh right for the role and who in your
opinion should be next
okay this is the full extent to which
i'm going to entertain this question
so i have not addressed the persistent
rumor
that jody whitaker will be leaving
after series 13. uh it is possible
there is reason to believe that it's
credible but it's not official and it's
still
until it's official i have no opinion
and i do this largely for my own sanity
because there are so many rumors out
there that if i don't have a hard line
somewhere and for me that hard line is
is it rumor or is it confirmed with
very very very very few exceptions
will i ever comment on something that is
a rumor because
i don't like to waste my time
nor do i like to waste my brain energy
on something that isn't
real and most rumors
don't turn out to be that way i'd rather
be right than early
with it like that seems to be the
opposite opinion on youtube because you
know there's all these videos like
oh here's the rumor it's like and they
jumped on it as soon as that as it came
out i'm like
you guys want to jump on it and say you
were there early that's fine i don't
i would rather wait until i know now as
to the question you
actually asked me i get to him
eventually
i don't have a pig i never have a pick
because
i i don't
pre-pick who i hope they cast
for the same reason that i don't have
dream castings
for superhero roles or anything like
that
because that creates an image of my mind
of what i want something to be and then
if it
isn't that exact thing i'm going to be
coming at it from a
negative point of view of like oh but i
wanted something else
i'd much rather hold a neutral position
as best as i possibly can
until i actually find out what it is
they're doing and then i'll have an
opinion on that
i mean i've done a video on 10 actors
who i think would be great in the park
i'll basically default to that if you
want to look it up
um but
yeah i honestly
whatever whatever logistical
knot needs to be untied just have it be
joe barton it could because honestly
if joe martin never gets a proper series
this was pointed out uh by the who
chaser
um it was something i had not taken into
account but he's right
if joe martin never gets a proper series
or at the very least a friggin special
all to herself but really it should be a
proper series
then that is going to be a
waste and also kind of offensive
that the first black doctor
didn't actually get a proper series
and is immediately relegated as an also
ran
and doesn't get to stand in the same
level as all of the official
doctors they need they need
to make her properly official and i'm
not saying like
oh she's not getting no she's canon
but having her be this sidebar
who doesn't even get a number
no that's that's actually kind of a big
problem
okay i know i'm i'm falling so far
behind there was a
some super chats that came up i got
stuff to catch up on here
at this one i think because i i uh
admitted to
having the tax issue the um
the super chats are more lively which
means they are going to get the focus
folks so
i'm not ignoring you i'm just um
paying attention to the people who pay
me money
sorry not sorry
have you ever watched steven universe
the first half of season one feels
episodic but has great foreshadowing and
world building season four is a low
point but i'd say it's a great show
overall
i haven't seen it i will finally
soon i think because hbo max
finally finally sorted out their crap
with roku so now i can actually stream
it to something other than my phone
or my computer so
right now i'm not i'm not gonna start
until i um
finish avatar the last airbender i'm
almost done the second season of that
stevie universe might be the next thing
that i like plug away at while i'm like
on the exercise bike
so it it will hopefully happen
relatively soon but
not quite yet
if joe martin isn't cast as 14 i want
ramen
takaram i'm not sure who that is so no
opinion
uh a lot of the time with doctor who the
fans
who have an idea of casting are only
referring to their previous work
i'm usually pleasantly surprised that's
another part of the reason that i don't
really entertain casting
notions in my head whether it's doctor
who or anything else because honestly
most of the best performances a lot of
my favorite performances from a lot of
things
came from actors who i never would have
thought to have cast in that
it's part of why i i always thought that
like
after fantastic beasts came out so many
people were like oh eddie redmayne
should be the next doctor
like what an unimaginative answer
because they basically decided they
wanted newt scaman the preference to
give his
commander as the next doctor i'm like no
i don't want the performance as the
doctor to be
reheated leftovers from another part the
actor has done
i want it to be something new or
something fresher and i feel like
all the other um
actors who have played the dark so far
brought that i don't
like the the only one that i kind of
bent that rule at a little bit all is
patterson joseph
because i admit that i want him because
of how good he was
as the marquita carabass in
neverwhere but
that thing is so underappreciated as it
is
like i'll make an exception
do you have anything special planned for
the 50th anniversary
of the masters this year not presently
i i can't keep track of my own
anniversaries much less
anniversaries of anything else i'm
really bad
at that like i i i've
never really properly done uh like a
halloween theme
i've barely done holiday themed stuff
i i can't i can't keep track
my schedule catches up on me and the
calendar is
freaking relentless
all right i gotta i gotta just jump down
to the bottom i'm gonna miss a bunch of
these
do you prefer happy energetic doctors or
the moody doctors well
personally i prefer a nice fully rounded
doctor but if you're going to make me
choose
i would i prefer the happier ones
sorry late have you seen the expanse on
amazon it's great uh
no uh that well first of all thank you
glenn mcknight oh and i didn't
thank whoever the previous super chat
was
i gotta get better at that oh it was mr
wool guitar again
cool did i get the one before that the
steven universe question
no i didn't that was from high voltage
thank you um
so no i haven't seen the expanse i've
heard great things about it i know jesse
gender loves it
and um definitely has recommended it
but no as yet i i haven't seen it
i really hope that
excuse me just got a
uh raspberry seed down the wrong pipe
um i hope that rumor is not true
uh about jody i kind of hope it isn't
too
um but like it may be like
the thing is when i say i it's still
just a rumor that's not me refuting it
it may very well turn out to be true
i just am not gonna sink the energy into
it before then
do you agree it was too bagful that
breaking bad originally came off as a
dark sitcom oh yeah
that first season is totally a dark
sitcom
re-watch it if you haven't in a while
what are your hopes for the 13th
doctor's character going forward
how do you feel about her
get away from me how do you feel about
her feeling angry
tor about the timeless child is that a
route you'd like to see them
take given it can't be avoided well um
first of all thank you jack warren
um i would
kind of prefer
that she would be a little bit more
philosophical
and inquisitive as opposed to angry
i don't like the doctor being motivated
by anger for
anything more than like one rash
decision
or one brash action
um the the idea of doing an extended arc
for the 13th doctor where anger or
rage is the primary driver that notion
really kind of
that doesn't sit well with me
um all right
so let's see oh geez i got more super
chats in
thank you all very much my goodness
uh thank you again real life jolie
let me get it up here
oh speak of music uh what do you think
about the modern
the mountain the modern goats the
mountain goats
and also of what of jamie bamber
of hornblower and bsg fame
for a doctor's companion
so i i don't know who the mountain goats
are
and i don't know who jamie bamber is i
don't know hornblower and i
never watched battlestar galactica
[Music]
um what
uh yeah i i feel really bad
that you're paying money to ask me a
question that i i legitimately can't
answer
oh did jessie ah i've never seen
battlestar yes jesse i've never seen
this feels like a role reversal that
we've got going on right now
i i'm afraid you're about to tell me
that that's the next podcast project
once uh what the frill is up
thank you very much beatrix purvis
happy new year i love the lipstick color
thank you
i i do enjoy the uh the darker every now
and then
any thoughts on the new set of star trek
shows compared to the previous
generation and is cisco still the best
captain anyway you're awesome
um see for me picard is still the best
captain because
i while i've liked cisco i haven't seen
all that much of deep space nine
and i really haven't seen enough to have
a
opinion on that um
or at least on him specifically
um so the the new stuff they've got
going on right now because they've got
the
they've got the show with pike who i
don't really know because i haven't
watched discovery yet
and they've got um
lower decks and they've still got
discovery and they've got picard i'll
tell you what they
are moving forward with confidence which
is something that i am happy to see from
star trek
because it really felt like for a long
time they were moving forward with the
sense of
uh we don't want to make anybody mad at
us i think that was part of why they
kept cycling back and doing prequel
stuff and refusing to move the timeline
forward for as long as they freaking did
so i i feel like at least there is
there's a sense of boldness to this
current
crop of star trek um
entertainment that i feel like was kind
of lacking before
prodigy section 31 good grief
they may have overdone it a little bit
so okay i gotta i got more super chats
what we got
uh peter wayne
i probably butchered that i'm so sorry
glenn you stole my shtick
i'm the one who pesters vera about the
expanse
happy new year uh everyone hope 2021 is
starting off well for everyone well
i'll tell you what that uh that first
week of 2021 was a hell of a year
um and like
a lot of people bug me about
stuff that i have haven't watched yet um
on here so you know i think that i think
you can share the load
on that there's there's plenty of uh of
pestering to go around
thank you very much tracy oh wow just a
head start on the give birth some
breathing room fun
yeah fingers crossed um i suppose
like once i i actually catch up on these
i might sort of give you some of the
ideas i'm going to try and pull together
for
the next one because i am going to try
and do something a little bit more like
a telethon and like have it be a bigger
thing from my end um
have you seen the horror that is son of
the mask no
and i won't unless somebody pays me
oh let's see here
uh any doctor who villains you'd like to
see return for the 13th season omega
jesus uh
i saw your vermont governor was a
republican which surprised me should it
no vermont has
a pretty long history of having
a split between the parties
in the state house and and the governor
it's lined up every now and then but
honestly it um
it it's hard to explain if you don't
live here
it makes sense if you do and also like
i'll point out
i'll point out two things i don't like
phil scott
very much like he's not terrible
and he certainly is no fan of trump's
which helps but
i i want i want to find out the name
of what teacher he had in his childhood
who treated him so badly that he has
developed this career-long
vendetta against teachers
because he screws over teachers in the
state
every single freaking chance he
gets so i definitely have issues with
the guy
but i
have a hard time even calling him a
republican like he
is but i feel like calling him that
i feel like i'm calling him a bad name
because he does not feel representative
of what party
is at this point it probably helps that
as the governor he only has to worry
about this state
he doesn't really have to worry about
the national level
so like a vermont republican is not
a national level republican
it's kind of a different can of worms
that said not endorsing the guy
don't like him wish he hadn't won
reelection
okay
uh have you seen the macra terror power
of the dogs faceless ones or fury from
the deep animations i have seen power of
the daleks that i have a review
up for it i have not seen the rest
um thank you very much high voltage
for the super chat honestly why do you
think they haven't done
an alien historical companion yet it
can't be that hard to write classic who
did it multiple times
i don't know
i am so sick
of every companion
from modern day freaking earth
i'm so sick of it it's so
uninventive it's so unimaginative and
the show has been going on for long
enough
now at this point that the idea of oh
well we need a
person from the modern day to bring in
the no you don't
thing's gonna hit it's 13 series you
don't need that
logistically part of it is probably a
desire to have a reason to keep coming
back to modern day earth
because that helps with the budget
if the companions are from modern day
earth then it makes more sense that the
doctor keeps coming back from modern day
earth and they can have things set in
locations and sets that are
general use and easily put together in
cheap anything that they set in space
or in the past or whatever is going to
require more
dress setting more period related stuff
more um building of props or what have
you it's more expensive
but even taking that into account
fine still have them coming back to
modern day earth but just give me a
companion from out of our time
have them cope with what it's like in
modern day earth
ah
so sick of it it's so freaking
unimaginative
uh am i caught up i might be
i think i might be caught up on the
super chats i'm checking
trying to be thorough yes
okay so jump me back down to the bottom
of the chat
so i skipped over a bunch of stuff
uh what do you think of mr beast for
president
are you asking my opinion on the
outgoing president or are you referring
to
the uh character from trans metropolitan
known as the beast
who was also the outgoing president
saw an article back in 17 that claimed
bill was from the 80s i honestly felt
let down
yeah i had hoped that based off her
fashion sense
that's obviously the assumption the
article had made didn't point
pan out that way i actually want a
caveman companion
that might be a little much for me but
like jamie is awesome
he's a freaking highlander
oh like it's not hard
on new year's eve instead of saying
happy new year i shouted jumanji so
hopefully we're out of the game
or this is the next level i i do i do
worry that we are
about to run a boss gauntlet
the main issue i had with the eaters of
light is that i was expecting a lot more
from the woman
who wrote survival i forgot it was the
same i still haven't seen survival
shh it's all my classics i need to get
to
list boreo sequenza 3
is an experimental composition where the
end result is effectively just an
incomprehensible noise
perfect for singing on a live stream
without being demonetized
it's funny there was something i did on
tick tock today
i did a duet singing to a sea shanty
um and kind of stretched
my um my vocal muscles
from my base range which i haven't
tapped in a long time
i'm going to roll the dice on something
here because i'm pretty sure
i i can't i can't remember the lyrics to
the sea shanty now but
there is a song that i know and i
remember my bass range 4
that i am pretty sure is in the public
domain
so i think i'm okay we'll see
you load 16 tons what do you get
another day older and deeper in debt
say peter don't you call me cause i
can't go
out my soul to the company's store
um i'm a bit technically i'm a baritone
but um you know i've got i uh depending
on how a piece of music is divvied up if
they haven't distinguished between
baritones and bases you're gonna want me
with the bases not the tenors
there were more super chats came in
i wonder if the reason we haven't had
companions from the past is they might
bring prejudice baggage that
make them hard to sympathize with only
if you bring it up
that's only there if the writers decide
to put it there
so that that's the kind of uh objection
that like i just don't
really buy that oh thank you again real
life jolie
um agreed about the darn modern day
companion thing i mean seriously
i would love to see the likes of jamie
bamber come in in his hornblower role
clearly that's something i need to check
out at some boys at some boys
point yeah oh swooning carowind
you're okay you're okay uh what are your
thoughts on the mask 1994. i haven't
rewatched it in a while
to my memory it was one of the jim
carrey movies that held up a little
better than others
today's menu creamy chicken and wild
rice soup
cinnamon roll bites ooh tasty i would
never guess you could sing bass like
that
oh thought i saying tenor based on my
speaking voice you would think
i'd like i cannot get
to the upper end of tenor like it it
breaks and you can hear me straining
it's a bad
it's a bad look thank you very much
selena kyle what's your biggest guilty
pleasure movie
any genre
um
i can think of a couple i have that like
i know
aren't good movies but i still enjoy
like i still like
gi joe rise of cobra and i still like
the remake
for the house on haunted hill and i
still like the masses of the universe
with dolph lundgren
those are probably oh you know what
earth girls are easy that might that
might be the one i need to go with
oh boy that i should feel guilty about
liking that one
i don't i don't really do guilt over
entertainment but that's
um whoo do you watch
uh she's leftist streamer youtuber i
don't because
his presence his presentation style
isn't really my jam i'm familiar with
him i know of him
um
sir jedi sentinel example of it's it's
not hard for the companions and arnold
see that's the thing like technically
we've had
some like with nardole but
nardole is secondary as a companion
like he doesn't even come on a lot of
their outings
in the start of the the thing he's
secondary in the same way rory is
now i like nardole or at least i like
him by series 10.
um he wasn't great in um
husband's river song like at all to the
point that i was really nervous him
coming back he
proved to be pretty good later though if
labyrinth ever makes it to broadway you
should play jareth
you remind me of the babe
uh did you know there's going to be a
set of audio dramas with peter davidson
and david tennant i did
i am like so far behind on big finish
related stuff though that
the idea of new stuff coming out like
intimidates me
you can only choose one beetlejuice or
big fish beetlejuice
uh any tips on starting a channel i just
started a channel
inspired by a counselor of geeks called
time card
tyro and i would love tips for content
oh my god um
i don't have a lot of tips on how to
get started doing this i mean i
i can give you oh discord thank you for
the reminder carowind um
at this latest super chat that'll hop on
the discord
um the the thing is that
i can give you a couple of broad pieces
of advice
don't feel married to a topic or a
format
allow yourself the freedom to
mess with it especially early on because
once you
start if if and i do mean if
like it's harder to break in on this
platform than it
ever has been if you start to build a
following
and they go in for a certain format it's
going to be harder to break from it
but feel free to experiment early on
with format with topic to find what you
want to do because if you
over specialize and go over niche in
terms of your topic
you're gonna burn through top you're
gonna burn through
things to talk about a lot sooner than
you think you're going to
and have a regular upload schedule
so that people know when to expect new
videos from you
and a regular reliable output also helps
with the algorithm
now the algorithm's still not going to
favor you
probably until you have at least a
thousand subscribers which can be a slog
it took me five years to get my first
thousand i don't recommend this gig
um to people just coming in and i hate
to be discouraging but those are the
general things that i'm that i'm gonna
say
so i got another super chat from selena
love it earth girls are easy that earns
an extra 10 bucks
oh that movie oh
where you guys from finland oh boy
if folks haven't seen that one it's um
it's a trip that thing
okay let me just pull this up and check
the discord reminder
the council of geeks discord server is a
thing it exists
it is a patreon perk
and there's also another way to
guarantee that your questions get
answered in the live stream
aside from super chats so let's see what
we've got here
uh will you try american gods season
three
now uh now it's coming out season two
was very disappointed i don't remember
if you
can if you were commissioned to review
um i was commissioned to review the
first two seasons of american gods
i don't have the service that american
gods season three is
airing on i have no intention of
watching at this point season two was
such a mess
and the behind the scenes stuff that's
gone on does not give me any confidence
whatsoever in the third season and the
trailer did very little for me
i was slightly surprised watchman did
not make your best of 2020 is because
it is genuinely not which is finer
because you have not finished
posting the reviews etc well um
let me double check something really
quick because now i am
just i want to check something before i
say it but yet part of it
is i have not finished the tv series
and the other part is
um let me check
i was right show's not from 2020 shows
from 2019.
so it actually wasn't in the running
anyways
you gave me a panic moment there and and
actually um
if if it had been a 2020 show i would
have rushed through
uh the last few episodes so that it i i
could have considered putting it on the
list but it was
never in contention for that reason uh
next up
my boyfriend and i are watching the
torchwood episode cyberwoman
[Laughter]
and we disagree on whether or not a
cyberman cyberperson
should be sexy your opinion well
let's preface it by saying i ain't gonna
kink shame if you find
cyber implants sexy and that's your jam
i ain't gonna yuck your your yum so
let's start
there should a cyber person
be sexy in the way that cyberwoman was
sexy i.e
in a flippin bikini
no no they should not
core component of the cybermen as a
concept
is body horror and the terrible things
that human beings will do
as a society and as individuals to
themselves
in order to keep surviving if it looks
sexy
then you've you've undercut your point
so no no they shouldn't
i think even if the answer to that is oh
this person's kind of answering that
question
i'm going to read this anyway i think
even the answer is yes an argument could
be made that it
is since it's about manipulating yanto
in every possible way
um the actual costume design feels
gratuitous specifically because it does
not look like anything that could see
conceivably be thought of by cybermen
yep true
will there note a goal of eradicating
emotion and brutal pragmatism
about discarding anything not uh
immediately useful
yeah all that's true and like as far as
that episode's purpose where
yonto still needs to have hope first of
all
i think it would be way way way more
tragic
if she just looked like a cyberman and
there's no visual cue whatsoever that
this is definitely
his girlfriend who's converted he claims
that it is
but i actually i would have found it
really disturbing if there was no visual
proof
that would have been genuinely
disturbing
to see him over the body
of a generic cyberman could be
anybody insisting that this is his
girlfriend
and that she's still in there there
would be a tragedy
to that that honestly could be
heartbreaking
if delivered correctly
now obviously that episode
isn't really going for a tragedy because
for crying out loud they have a they
have a cyborg punch a pterodactyl in the
head
so clearly that's not the vibe they're
going for but even with the vibe they're
going for
with the idea that he knows that it's
definitely his girlfriend
and he's too taken up at that all you
need is her face
she does not need to be in a bikini
ha unnecessary okay popping back to the
chat
let's see all right i am now back
and i will be able to uh start seeing
your questions again didn't know if you
saw stuckman's new video where he
discussed
his jehovah's witness upbringing and
revealed among other things his
pansexuality thought it was awesome
to see him come out i i kind of dropped
off chris stuckman
not for any particular reason uh he
didn't do anything that ticked me off
i just i don't know over time i just
started to take to his style
uh less and less and i kind of bounced
off it
um like a couple years back when i was
just trying to clean up my
subscriptions but that's great that he
came out that's wonderful
i'm happy for him like i said like i i
don't
dislike chris doug man i i just haven't
i haven't watched his stuff in a while
it wasn't until i started watching uh
one on uk uh on amazon that i realized
that
both chris knowth and harriet walter
have both
appeared in the law and order franchise
yeah got well hell
everybody was on law and order franchise
at some point
could the tv watchman be watched without
reading the graphic novel thinking of
showing it to my dad
yes but you're gonna have to be prepared
to provide some cliff notes
um so one of you better like somebody
watching
needs to know to fill in some gaps and
honestly i think it's gonna
diminish the experience quite a bit to
not know the comic
because it is continuing that story and
it kind of assumes
that you know certain things it does not
do a ton of backfill
it does very little actually in terms of
the broad strokes of what happened
it doesn't really explain who dr
manhattan is
who rorschach is the squid
gets brought up um but not addressed in
terms of what it is until a bit after
the concept of it is brought up so
it kind of presumes that you know who
these people
are now if you're prepared to give him a
bullet point run down and he's amenable
to that he might still be able to get
into it for what it's doing but it is
building on foundation that it's best to
know
already
uh who would you rather play on broadway
sweeney todd or jareth
look if you gave me the chance to play
jareth i would happily play jareth
i saw an image uh on the reddit for
doctor who of 12 with a beard for the
60th and oh my god he looked so much
like clooney
that's an odd thought
what celebrity would you like to see a
doctor who episode about i personally
think alan turing
would be in a great episode none i don't
like
the i don't like the celebrity
historical figure episodes
almost never um
so i really would just rather not
will be goldberg wants to be the doctor
i saw that
i still don't think it should ever be an
american if it was going to be an
american honestly
yeah let her do it i think she'd kill at
it
i still would personally say no but
heck i don't know if you saw this
earlier in the discord but what's your
opinion on
tom felton as the doctor um
[Music]
curious i would be curious
oh thank you very much rusty ralston hey
it's rusty from the discord server
my discord account got disabled because
of spam aka
getting and responding to a bunch of
messages in a half hour
so yeah just in case you're wondering oh
was that an automated
thing that happened that's i hadn't
heard of anybody running into that
before
i'm hoping it's temporary
those sorts of things usually are like
they they put you in
like a time-out box sort of thing
i have an audition for uh high school
tomorrow wish me luck
have a good night everyone well best of
luck at your audition break a leg
uh i recently re-watched children of
earth and it creeps me out yes
um even more since i live in the area
where the episode was filmed
yep that would do it what's your opinion
on the valyard
it's not a concept that i think is it's
a concept that was more interesting on
paper than it was in execution
i'm not entirely sure it's worth
revisiting
i wouldn't say it's impossible to do
something better with it but
[Music]
i don't know the idea of paul rubins is
either the mong
or the toymaker is now in my head
i never really liked paul rubens that
much
i never went in for peewee uh do you
think joe martin doctor
is a token without her own story um
yeah yeah or at least
um she risks being that
it if the first
and to date only
black incarnation of the doctor
um and no don't don't
give me that oh well we saw some
incarnations of the timeless child
regenerating they were but that doesn't
freaking count you know it
if the only real proper
incarnation of the doctor that's black
only gets to appear in a supporting role
to support
a white version of the doctor
and never gets her own story at any
point
yeah i think tokenism
would be a word that uh would be fair
if you were given the opportunity to be
the showrunner for doctor who would you
take it
yes i'd probably fail
like let's be clear i i have i do not
believe i have the secret ingredients
that
people with years and years of
professional experience in television
don't have but you know
if you're going to hand me the the gears
to the keys to the airplane
i'm going to dang well try and fly it
you know
it's a bit like i
when i lived in new york i
i don't think i've ever told this story
on here
so
i lived in new york i
um i i started performing in
burlesque shows um because
um i i discovered burlesque and i found
it much more welcoming and more to my
sort of instincts as a performer much
better suited for me than drag was which
is what i've been doing before
so i uh i think it was responding to
this
thing from a um from this sort of
basement
um it was literally called the the
franco underground theater the theater
was literally underground it was this
basement
black box theater and i went thinking
that
what i thought what i was going to do
was going to talk to him about
being part of a show that he was putting
together
what ended up transpiring over the
course of the conversation was he was
actually looking for someone to bring
a burlesque variety show to the space
and offered me who had never produced a
show in my life
the chance to do that
i did and i had no business doing it
i was okay at some aspects
other parts i really didn't know what i
was doing you could tell
i do not intend to ever produce a show
again
but i was given the opportunity i'm like
well
let's see if this thing flies or if i
crash it into a mountain i didn't fully
crash into the mountain i do
i do think i uh i scraped along a few
peaks though
so like i am the kind of person you give
me an opportunity that big
i'm probably gonna take it
uh despite the terror
star shrek don't know why that's in the
chat
but apparently star shrek is a thing
donkey file proton torpedoes
i don't know that was part shrek part
scotty part
i have no idea
ah that was gonna be a sip but i just
kept going with it
genuine question what's the difference
between dragon burlesque oh
okay so drag
so i i'm gonna put it through the lens
for me because broadly speaking there's
quite a bit of difference because at its
core
drag is about um
gender exaggeration and gender
impersonation it is about
doing a big over-the-top campy version
of performative gender and i'm being
vague like that because there are drag
kings
there are drag queens there are cis
women who i have seen be
drag queens and they have every right to
call themselves as drag queens the same
level same huge hair massive makeup
it you are portraying a massive
campy exaggeration of a certain gender
that is what drag is
burlesque
is stripping it is the it
is the artistic version of stripping and
i'm not saying artistic in this case
to denigrate more traditional strippers
like in a strip club or pole dancers
because most of them
are incredibly athletic and
can do things on a pole that i would
kill myself doing like that is an insane
skill what they can do
but burlesque is
my approach to burlesque and this is not
everyone's approach but my approach to
burlesque
is that stripping while a part of it an
inherent
part of it of the performance
burlesque needs feathers it doesn't need
it they are a bit of a trope as our fans
uh and garters but no you don't need it
here's the thing
for me what makes it burlesque
is that the stripping is not the point
it's there it's the medium
through which you are doing something
maybe you are telling a story maybe
you're trying to evoke a certain emotion
maybe you're trying to make people hot
and sweaty
maybe you're trying to make them think
maybe you're trying to scare them
maybe you're trying to make them laugh i
have seen burlesque done for comedy
for horror as political
action always
involving a strip element
but um
that stripping is just the way that
it's being communicated so drag is a
costume
sort of drag is an aesthetic drag is
about
dialing up performative gender to 11.
that's what drag is um
and and there can be bleed over between
drag and burlesque insofar
as they can both they are both capable
of being similarly over the top
but um they're they're sort of two
different ends and
the cons the things that are consistent
about it are different
burlesque the consistency is stripping
and there are drag burlesque performers
and there are some drag performers who
incorporate stripping
but it's not an inherent part of the
medium just like
exaggerating performative gender
presentation is not an inherent part of
burlesque there's
there's venn diagrams with crossover but
they are kind of
different things if we are using
actors from that franchise i prefer
rupert grint over felton
i'm finally a ginger i don't like it uh
or for real daniel kaluuya perfect for
the next doctor
daniel kaluuya would that would i could
get behind that
that'd be really interesting oh hey
stephen i didn't see you come in
very nice burlesque is the gentleman's
tease
personally i prefer an audience of
ladies
i'm 14 so needless to say i have not
seen burlesque as well you
shouldn't give it four years have a
blast
flashback to your sweet lightsaber
skills
i did enjoy that number disney is
remaking home alone what are your
thoughts
why
that's it that's all i got a doctor
who's story idea
the tardis splits in half and lands the
doctor in one time period the companions
and another
but they can still hear each other
through the time vortex
okay my first question then is
what what is
preventing the doctor from just piloting
his half to where they are
that's the first thing you're going to
have to figure out because obviously
that's going to be your eventual
resolution
so you have to figure out what's keeping
that from happening right away
can you hum you'll be back
[Laughter]
i'm still waiting for the bio pic by the
robert
robin thick blurred lines copyright case
it could be a series of
american crime story um could be
you'll be back
[Music]
it's literally in half the doctor only
has half the consult okay so then
how are you going to resolve that
so like what what is the solution
what the story possibilities of that are
really kind of depend on what your
eventual solution is
you may have to start at the end and
work backward
given 13 seems to be tech focused as a
doctor i'm surprised she hasn't
built a campaign like a did in an audio
um
i wish handles had gotten a proper
series as a companion
handle should have had a series as a
companion
missy should have had a series as a
companion
yeah uh how would you actually do for a
brochure in the new era like would you
do a cgi penguin
or have him in human form i don't
i don't think
that you will be able to get
audiences mainstream audiences to
swallow the concept of furbisher
frobisher
what you what you probably have to do is
have him human
establish that he's a shapeshifter maybe
briefly see him as a penguin or have him
have a tossed up line like
you know normally i prefer normally i
prefer to be a penguin but you know
i'm trying to blend in something like
that
do you find interest in true crime i
really don't
um like knowing that this stuff is
like it's not because my head's in the
sand like i know the kind of stuff that
goes on but like going into detail
on things that have actually happened
like that
very rarely interests me especially
because true crime has a tendency to
really zone in on
particularly gruesome
um crimes
like i'd be much more interested in a
true crime of of a heist
sure but like ah
somebody dies like i don't know and
maybe i'm maybe i'm just getting old but
i'm also at a point where i feel like
the genre as a whole especially with
having exploded in the last few years in
podcast and streaming format just feels
ghoulish um just knowing that people are
dead
and people are making their careers and
their paycheck
sifting through corpses to for
entertainment
rubs me up the wrong way i don't judge
anyone who does like it but just me
does he's making two star wars movies
rogue squadron one directed by kevin
feige what are your thoughts
last i knew fight you wasn't directing
he was pulling it together
same way he pulls together but he's not
a director he's never been a director
um so we don't know enough about that
one in the rogue squadron i'm curious
and that's about all i've got
um let's see
what about a humanoid duck companion
only if they're named scrooge
coming right up series 12 starring joe
martin as the
doctor companions are missing handles
12 missy boars and handles that would be
a good series oh
db you are you're teasing me now
uh
anyone else having their faith in uh
oh saying hang on anybody else having
their faith in
humanity being overly tested in the last
year yeah
a little bit handles was voiced by
kevin novak who was wise for four lions
oh i did not realize that
sing the gestures recap song
i do like that song um i would have to
do it on tik tok till it would get
flagged on here i'm
pretty sure
what are your thoughts on an american
doctor who companion none because there
shouldn't be an american doctor next
question
the making biopic on david bowie uh
yet his wishes were not to do that what
do you think
and i i really wish they wouldn't have
but they were gonna do it inevitably
anyways
is spaceball is better than the star
wars prequels that's an unfair
comparison
i enjoy it more but it's like it's
setting out to accomplish
very very different things
this week i'm watching the first classic
who story my uncle got me
on the anniversary of his death after
that i'm going to watch all of classic
who in order
best of luck to you
my favorite line is she's tilting pretty
sharply bitchwood
yeah liz and i like that lion a lot too
uh can i get away with this
poor matalana though has lost her
saintly glow
in fact she's tilting pretty sharply
bitchwood
oh i love that show so much
i don't want to get up to turn off the
light he do it for me oh yeah
andrew don't worry about it you you head
on out i'll get it before i go
uh where would you rank the ruth dr
tardis in relation to the others i need
to look at it again i haven't rewatched
that episode
uh in a bit i have to kind of study it
probably
upper mid i remember liking it you
should have a companion from mainland
europe
just to drive the brexiters mad
one from brussels specifically just to
drive them
up the wall have it be a bossy
person from brussels who's really into
regulation and rules
watch all of their heads explode
and they and they hate uh prong crisps
that'll be like their quirk
thoughts on the producers either version
it's fun
i enjoy the movie but it's not
particularly well filmed though
i love it when you hum
[Music]
all right let me see if i ah
how much you want about i won't be able
to do this
if um people are watching i used to be
able to
see if i still can
[Music]
uh that's whistling and humming at the
same time
that's a perfectly useless parlor trick
what do you mean
have you seen the queen's gambit i have
not as yet
my boyfriend and i were pleasantly
surprised to see michelle gomez playing
a creepy childish dental nurse on a
sitcom we were watching repeats of oh my
goodness
if there's a broadway rocky horror
revival who would you play
oh i
i would have a very hard time
picking between riffraff and frank
frank is more consistently in my range
riffraff strains me
but i love that character a lot
how can i deal with my lgbt phobic
far-right religious extremist mother i'm
living on my own but she visits
frequently
ah
i don't know
um
so here's something i i don't really
talk about but
um i have family
locally not my mother thankfully
but i do have family locally you know
who are people i
would see when i was growing up and i
have good memories of and
[Music]
i've always liked to think the best of
who
[Music]
are trump supporters
and voting for him the first time
i came to terms with that
but watching and hearing about them
continuing to support him and
repeat the talking points
of the far right of people i genuinely
feel to be dangerous
i think it's a very real possibility
that there's an entire swath of my
family like blood family this isn't like
related by marriage is this my blood
that i'm probably never gonna
voluntarily spend time with again
because i don't think i'll ever be
comfortable doing so
because i know that no matter what they
say to me in private
that they voted for
and supported
people acting directly
against my best interest and
towards my suppression
how's that to punctuate a point um
and as the
second election was coming up i
realized that i probably wasn't really
ever going to see them again
not in any meaningful way and definitely
not comfortably
and that's the better option
because there'll be nothing good for
me that would that would come of that so
i wish i had um
better advice
i don't know what you do when it's your
mother
and somebody who you do see on a regular
basis because i can choose not to see
these family members i have chosen not
to see these family members
but
unfortunately probably the only thing
you can do
realistically
is just not talk politics talk about
anything else
make it a no-go conversation topic
but that is still going to leave you in
a position where
you still know that they hold these
feelings and
how you cope with that i don't know
because what i've
done is to cut people out
and it sucks
i should wrap it up i've run long on
this one
but okay so let me before i do
oy eek ah sorry
kicking stuff i'm making noises
all right don't know what that was
so the next one two weeks from now
as i said is going to be
a you look like you would be a tenor a
lot of people would think so
but no
[Music]
it's more 16 tons again
get away with a little of this one i
think
the misty mountains
cold
[Music]
so anyway
next live stream in two weeks
i am going to be okay
and a super chat comes in you people
just love to keep me around
i ain't gonna ain't gonna object that
much thank you very much
dave wolford uh where can i go to listen
to all doctor who audiobooks i checked
audible they don't have
volume 2 of the 10th doctor well i like
are you talking audio books or audio
dramas because audio drama you need to
go to big
finish audio books i don't
know
some of it might have to do with where
you're located because
sometimes some of the rights for some of
the audiobooks are
restricted out of uh
certain territories and i don't know why
i've run into that
uh not with doctor who specifically but
oh caroline
i see what you're doing
okay so
what i was saying
next live stream in two weeks let's see
how far into the statement
um i can get this time
i'm gonna attempt something along the
lines of a telethon
because well first of all big thanks to
all the um
super chats in this one um a lot more
than a standard
probably because i said that i've got
the the tax bill thing going on but the
next one is going to be a much more
deliberate
um attempting to raise money towards
that
now um i'm going to be doing i'm
working on a couple of things um and
it's going to be things
like some things i've done before like
i'll do some mad libs with folks
i am thinking about doing a
reading of some of my
unpublished short works possibly of the
first chapter of the novel
um i am looking into
maybe uh trying to get some other people
on to the stream
we'll see no promises on that
don't sneeze again
um and
uh things of things along those lines
um and i'm open to um
of course steven i figured that was
coming um and there will
there will probably be um the option for
me to take
shots for a certain level of super chat
because i've done that before to some
pretty decent success
um might
subject myself to these things for your
entertainment they're like birdie bots
every flavored beans but aren't
um branded with the uh
intellectual property of a transphobe so
um that kind of stuff and i'm also open
for
suggestions keep in mind
i can't really sing anything that's
outside the public domain because it
risks
getting the stream shut down or even if
not shut down having the archive version
demonetized
so that i can't do that
but any other suggestions of
uh for things to do for this i am
definitely open to
feel free to hit me up on twitter or
email or
discord if you're in the discord server
now here's a question for you ms wicked
wolf
are you on tick tock or you don't have
to be on you can actually view tick tock
without getting
the app you can view it online um
because i did one uh
about a month ago now i think uh
where the hercules mulligan thing
featured
oh thank you very much uh ichiban
official
fun fact the original little shop of
horrors was made with the remaining
budget and the same cast and nearly the
same script
as bucket of blood from 1959 it was also
filmed
in two days i mean that's um that's
roger corman for you
the the man knew how to stretch a buck
uh ellie kendrick mira from
game of thrones would be great as susan
isn't the actress who plays susan still
alive
just bring her back unless she doesn't
want to
do a live pre do a live reading of your
erotic play give the people what they
want
i can't read for two parts myself it
doesn't
work the flow sucks and i'm not going to
i'm not going to alternate voices i
would feel silly
public domain medley burlesque
performance
i'm definitely not going to risk
performing burlesque
on a live stream pretty sure by the
by the time i did i snapped open the top
layer the stream would get
shut down right away
uh so suggestions don't say doctor in
distress
okay here's the thing ben
i am considering
doing a live reaction
to doctor in distress as
part of
the telethon
understand that i'm going to have to
like watch it on my phone through
earphones so
if you want to know what i'm reacting to
you're going to have to cue it up on
your own side it'll be like when i
live streamed watching howard the duck
but i'm considering it
that's what the irs has driven me to
you sock puppet
i was gonna say heck was sock but i was
tempted to bust out the
actual puppet that i have but i don't
feel like moving all that stuff around
yeah it's gonna shift too much stuff i'm
not gonna get i'm not gonna get him out
i just stared him down for a minute
it's very good at a blinking contest
mean girls is
not reopening on broadway because of
covid
oh i didn't realize that any of
broadway was reopening you probably
don't care
um but who do you want for la uh who do
you want for the last smash bros
fighters don't have to be realistic but
i know when you want
see the thing is
i haven't played since melee i don't
even know who's on it now
so there's a very good chance that if i
name anything
it's already going to be on there um
but let me think
uh
i don't know
heck i'll go stupid and niche and say
the alien hominid
see if anyone even knows what the heck
i'm talking about debating whether your
star wars number or doctor who
regeneration number was the best
thank you very much i'm actually i think
i think i'm proudest of my
uh hat and kane
number which i've done a few times
and that's a gender bending number quite
proud of that one
i wonder who's watching me now
the irs uh always feeling
somebody's watching me yeah uh i do need
to wrap it up
alien hominid i understood that
reference with the sock pockets every so
often you have to aggressively mash your
hands together
see obviously you haven't read the play
because
if you had you know that wouldn't
actually occur just be just because
i wrote what is explicitly labeled an
erotic play
doesn't mean people are actually banging
on stage
i'm classier than that i'm really not
but that's not what i actually put
in the text of the thing because i
figured actors have to be willing to do
it not it but
it whatever super niche thing
um about to come up but have you heard
of the legendary
sagata sanchiro no
i just found your channel because of the
cowboy bebop video
wow really
that what that's not what i expect to
hear cited as the thing that brought
people to the channel
welcome that's awesome
these live streams always fall in school
hours where i live so the christmas
break is always great for me well it was
very nice
to have you um
i i do do you have peacock no i don't
have peacock i don't have
paramount plus i don't have hulu i i'm
not getting them i have too many already
i gotta stop um so
thank you very much for watching thank
you for your time
thank you for your generosity on this
come back in
two weeks and watch me make an utter flu
myself
for money
but most importantly take care of
yourself
be well be safe
be kind and
more important than that please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned mccabe